[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
appears walking on censor coming up
tonight these are the same green
converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her at the shooting
how about that
the moment of truth as matthew
mcconaughey bids to unite the states on
gun violence is this finally america's
trigger for change
and he's out but batting back a
world-class sportsman term world leader
the ousted imran khan's gripping
interview on putin boris johnson and
assassination threats when i entered
politics i actually had conquered my
fear of dying if i would advising
president putin i would not have gone
there a prime minister having a drinks
get together after work
would not even have made news here
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening i want to start
tonight with an image that i can't get
out of my head
it's this pair of green converse
sneakers
a hand-drawn
heart on the right toe
they belonged to maitai rodriguez a
nine-year-old girl who was gunned down
in the uvalde school massacre
18 other children and two teachers were
killed alongside her well last night the
actor matthew mcconaughey who was born
in a valdez spoke at the white house and
gave a speech that i believe will be a
seminal moment in america's gun violence
debate
he asked his wife camilla to bring those
shoes to the briefing room
camilla's got these shoes can you show
these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about
that i have a 10 year old daughter she
wears sneakers she loves to draw i can't
even begin to comprehend the scale of a
horror like this nobody should it's not
normal it's not okay
and it's clear that mcconaughey can't
comprehend it either he was visibly
stunned as he described meeting a
cosmetologist who worked with the bodies
of the tiny victims this is difficult
but we have to watch it
that's the task of making the victims
appears peaceful and natural as possible
for their open casket viewings
these bodies
were very different
they needed much more than makeup to be
presentable
they needed extensive restoration
why
due to the exceptionally large exit
wounds
of an ar-15 rifle
most of the body's so mutilated that
only dna test
or green converse
could identify
many children were left not only dead
but
hollow it's gut-wrenching isn't it and
once you have that appalling imagery in
your head there's no escaping it nor
should there be i don't think it's been
a more powerful or harrowing speech at
the white house briefing room maybe ever
and it was about so much more than just
raw emotion mcconaughey wasn't there to
take sides or to lecture responsible gun
owners to disarm
or to preach from a lofty hollywood
platform about the ignorance of one side
or the other he didn't take sides
he even spoke about valdev in the place
where he'd learned to be a responsible
gun owner himself
now this was an appeal to all americans
whatever their views about guns
you know what
every one of these parents wanted what
they asked us for they want to make
their loss of life
matter
but we heard from we heard from so many
people right families of the deceased
mothers fathers sisters brothers texas
rangers hunters border patrol and
responsible gun owners who won't give up
their second amendment right to bear
arms and you know what they all said
we want secure and safe schools and we
want gun laws that won't make it so easy
for the bad guys to get these damn guns
i mean who wouldn't want that it's just
common sense
what matthew mcconaughey has done is
changed the tone of the gun debate from
toxic charged partisan mustang to a more
respectful rhetoric intended to unify
americans to bring about change that
could potentially save countless
innocent lives but why has it taken an
actor to do this
well he wasn't really speaking as an
actor nor as a politician he was
speaking as a father as a man from a
valde a town his grief has become the
world's pain and to me
his speech felt like a turning point at
least i hope it is
got a chance right now to reach for and
to grasp a higher ground above
our political affiliations
we start
[Music]
by making
the loss of these lives
matter they have to otherwise
where are we
if you can't
make lives matter when 19 children are
gunned down at school well when can you
and if not now then when
well joining me now is fox nation host
tommy lehrer journalist and lawyer
gerardo rivera and former democrat mayor
and tv legend jerry springer welcome to
all of you three people with i guess
slightly different perspectives on all
this tommy i know your position very
pro-gun pro second amendment you've been
quite critical of mcconaughey today
herrera i know you think it was like me
a brilliant speech and you're a
conservative who says that which is
significant and jerry you and i have
discussed guns many times over the years
we've worked together uh and you're on
the democrat side of this before we get
into the debate there's a very
interesting clip i found from when i
interviewed matthew mcconaughey for good
morning britain about 18 months ago
about what he saw as the real
fundamental problem about democratic
debate right now listen to this
the extreme left and the extreme right
completely illegitimize
the other side or they exaggerate
that that side's stance into an
irrational state that that makes no
sense and that's not fair when either
side does that
harald i want to start with you because
i thought he really hit the nail on the
head there that all these debates now
guns abortion whatever it is
you get the extremities on both sides
you scream the loudest they abuse each
other they mock each other there's no
consensus anymore that the sides don't
come together and reach points of
agreement and what i thought was so
striking about mcconaughey's speech
yesterday was he didn't seek to be in
century he he wasn't really lecturing
either side about their behavior he just
wanted to try and bring people together
to try and bring some kind of sensible
move to try and stop this kind of thing
happening
i thought it appears that it was the
most brilliant heartfelt speech i had
ever heard about
gun control gun legislation responsible
gun ownership however you want to
characterize it
i think that people who
seek to belittle him as an actor or
product of hollywood
you know
brush over the fact that he was a dad
with children he is a dad with children
that is his birth town uh it was very
clear that it it ripped his heart out as
it as it should to all of us it was just
gut-wrenching uh it's it's just one of
those things appears that
i
my frustration about this is i don't
think any of it matters i don't think
that matthew mcconaughey's a speech i
don't think anyone is listening those
who are listening are already convinced
uh you know it's uh
the second amendment looms like this uh
you know this arbitrary uh
monstrous uh kind of edict that you must
allow even crazy people to have weapons
i i feel awful
about what happened everyone in the
united states everyone across the world
as you suggest in the uk and elsewhere
just feels that this has been
a savage savage event uh i just despite
matthew mcconaughey's eloquence and
believe me i really do believe this is
the best speech ever on this topic i i
fear nothing will happen people i mean
that's that's incredibly dispiriting to
hear that tommy i want to play another
clip that uh matthew mcconaughey said
this is where he he presented what he
felt were the things that needed to be
done so let's listen to this
we need to restore our family values
we need to restore
our american values
and
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum wage to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
221
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them
tell me what part of that doesn't make
complete sense and in particular in
light of what happened at a valdez
well i will say i do agree with him on
restoring family values and american
values and i think a lot of this
discussion in the tragedies that have
happened in our country both in new
valley and elsewhere across our inner
cities every single weekend where we see
violence running rampant and a culture
of lawlessness i think restoring
american values family values and
changing our culture is incredibly
important and i'm glad that he mentioned
that and brought it up and i'd like to
say i do give him a lot of credit for
his speech i'm not saying that his
speech was bad i'm not saying it
offended me i'm just saying this our
constitutional rights do not come from
matthew mcconaughey any other actor any
other athlete anybody if he wants to run
for office and be elected and change our
laws and policies i would encourage him
to go for it but i will say this when we
start unraveling gun control and gun
rights there is a discussion that can be
had peers and i'm not somebody that is
so staunch in my beliefs of the second
amendment that i don't believe there's
any room for a conversation i do believe
that there are i don't believe that
there's a problem with increased
background checks however when we start
talking about red flag laws this is
where we have to really unravel this and
have a discussion because there's a lot
in the second amendment community a lot
of folks that are very worried that
someone will be able to infringe upon
our right to gun ownership based on he
said she said saying oh this person's
crazy that person's crazy in a seeking a
vendetta that will infringe on someone's
constitution what about the specific
point tommy what about specific what
about this i'm not disputing you don't
raise valid points about red flag laws
it'd have to be run properly but on this
simple point that he was he's three
years too young
this shooter at uvalde to to buy a beer
but he could buy a semi-automatic rifle
with no training
what possible logic is there that you
shouldn't just raise as mcconaughey says
the age limit as a bare minimum to 21
for kids and make it the same majors for
buying a beer
well i have to ask you this pier anytime
where any time we're discussing raising
the age for things or changing policy we
need to ask is the government really the
solution here with this person who shot
his grandmother in the face and then
went on to shoot children in a massacre
would it matter if he was 18 or if he
was 21 are those that have mental
illness those that seek to destroy and
kill and terrorize do they care if
they're 18. okay but tell me okay
let me ask you this why have any laws
against anything if your belief is that
criminals will do it anyway why have
laws against murder armed robbery
anything i mean the whole point of law
isn't it is that you try you you're not
going to eliminate it mcconnell has said
we're not going to get rid of the
problem what you hope to do
by making further restrictions is you
reduce hopefully the level of gun
violence which as you know america isn't
just number one in the world for this
kind of thing it has more gun violence
than the next 21
wealthiest countries in the world
combined so there's clearly a problem i
think mcconaughey is just trying to work
out what can we all agree on and i just
don't think anyone i've not met anyone
in america frankly who thinks it makes
any sense that he couldn't buy a beer
for another three years but he could buy
a semi-automatic rifle i hear the
argument well he
he's old enough to be in the military
well yeah my brother was a british army
colonel just retired and you know he
when he was 18 went into the military
but he received strict training
regularly about his firearms uh
constantly updated training a civilian
doesn't need to do that they can just
wander down
uh pass a cursory background check and
buy a a military-style semi-automatic
rifle it's that that i think is crazy
jerry i want to bring you in on this
because you've always had a view about
this which i think i've i've shared
i accept completely by the way that as a
brit
uh it's not for me to change american
laws but do you think jerry coming from
the world of entertainment as he did now
but previously politics do you think
matthew mcconaughey and this
extraordinary speech could actually
affect change
well um
certainly it'll have some impact but the
fact is
the american people
are
virtually all or pretty close to all in
agreement on the major idea of some kind
of gun control
most americans absolutely believe that
we ought to have background checks that
there ought to be red flag laws that we
in fact most americans believe that we
ought to ban assault weapons so it's not
the problem that the american people
don't want the change the problem is in
a number of issues we have a system
whereby the government doesn't
necessarily represent the will of the
voters it's a structural problem in the
government so you can have a few united
states senators that can simply block
any reasonable legislation if you just
let it up to a vote of the american
people do you think for a second the
idea of background checks wouldn't pass
do you think for a second we wouldn't be
banning assault weapons i mean talk
about an issue that doesn't have another
side
other than killing people as one thing
and two possibly because you're a
collector what in the world does anyone
outside of the military need an assault
weapon for we don't let people have hand
grenades we don't let people have rocket
launchers it has nothing to do with the
second amendment every single right in
the constitution is permitted to be
regulated if there is a legitimate
governmental purpose so for example in
the constitution we have the right
americans have the right to travel we
have the right to get on airplanes and
go places when 9 11 happened
we had regulations of that right to
travel when we got on a plane now we
have to have our um luggage inspected we
have to empty our pockets we go through
metal detectors when you have free
speech which is the first amendment
there are regulations on that yelling
fire in a theater or at four o'clock in
the morning going with a loud speaker
during a residential neighborhood and
preaching your your gospel no the police
can come and say i'm sorry you're not
allowed to be using your microphone at
four o'clock in the morning in a
residential neighborhood we can have
regulations this is a four we can i
think i think that's absolutely yeah i
think that's absolutely correct i mean
geraldo i i suppose
it seems to me this only gets resolved
if the people that matthew mcconaughey i
think he includes himself responsible
gun owners in america
reach a an agreement that they are
prepared to bring in new restrictions
without that and i think that was where
mcconaughey was very clever he didn't
try and demonize gun owners he didn't
call for any gun bans
what he said was it's incumbent on
responsible gun owners to look in the
mirror to find humility
to find knowledge to find wisdom and to
find a way through this because the
world is watching you know i remember
covering sandy hook and thinking well
nothing will be the same again as it
wasn't after 9 11 as jerry said and yet
nothing changed and here we are 10 years
later and you have almost an exact
replica of what happened at sandy hook
we do first of all i'd like to say hi to
uh mayor springer my former colleague in
the daytime talk arena jerry great uh to
be able to show you tommy i see much
more often
you know piers i wish that i had a more
optimistic message i wish that as in
most of human nature what you said was
true that the consensus wants this and
therefore ultimately this will happen
this is not that situation as you
personally experience peers in your u.s
tenure
this is a lobby that is
absolutely intransigent there is no
movement whatsoever for example ever
since the parkland massacre in florida
i i had happened to have dinner with
president and mrs trump a private dinner
just the the the family it was actually
the president and his sons
laura at mar-a-lago and we the president
had just left the hospital parkland
hospital and he had seen the damage
caused by that military-style assault
weapon how it had uh evaporated entire
uh limbs and heads and uh you know
eviscerated these people how it was uh
you know he had never seen anything like
it he was he was deeply shaken and he
was moved so i proposed to him i said mr
president
nicholas cruz the shooter in this case
with 19 years old how can it be that he
can't have a beer as you said pierce and
he can buy this weapon how can that be
that he can access that the same thing
in sandy hook with adam lanza the same
thing recently in buffalo and of course
in uvalde where you have these teenagers
that are absolutely restricted in u.s
law from alcohol consumption by driving
a truck or anything like that but yet
they can buy these weapons i propose to
the president a juvenile assault weapons
ban a juvenile assault this we can do
this we can get the age from 18 to 21
i'm not banning anything i'm not taking
any of your assault weapons i have this
modest step logical step if you can't
drink a beer you can't buy an assault
weapon let's just do that and i swear to
god i have seen the iron doors closed
like i said
i hope that's not the case i mean
i just want to end this debate with just
playing one more clip this is dr roy
guerrero he was the pediatrician who
actually witnessed and had to treat some
of the young bodies
and he said this
two children whose bodies have been
pulverized by bullets fired at them
decapitated
whose flesh had been ripped apart
that the only clue at their identities
was a blood splattered cartoon clothes
still clinging to them
i don't know how anyone can listen to
stuff like that about kids in classrooms
when they should be nurturing their
lives and being tall educating moving on
and not actually want to do something so
i just hope people listen to that speech
by mcconaughey listen to the testimony
today of the young kids who smeared
themselves with their friends blood in
the classrooms so that they could
pretend to be dead
listen to these people who had to treat
these bodies and then look at that pair
of sneakers and understand that the
mother of that little girl mighty
that they could only recognize that
little girl from her sneakers and if
that doesn't affect change i really
don't know what ever will
um thank you to my panel i really
appreciate it and i think i want to
carry on mr bait in the spirit that
matty mcgonagall wants to do it which is
not to demonize anyone on any of the
sides here just to somehow try and
affect some change so thank you to jerry
hirado and tommy i much appreciate it
well i said the next ousted pakistan
prime minister and former playboy
cricketer imran khan on politics putin
and survival
i have no fear of dying from your point
of view in britain of what i know
i understand that you expect from your
leadership the standards you expect them
to lead by example
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough nonsense
but now an interview with a giant of
world sport even bigger giant of world
politics imran khan was one of the
finest cricketers on the planet over 10
years as captain of pakistan he became
the nation's hero and then later
sensationally it's prime minister but he
was deposed after losing an acrimonious
confidence vote uh in april so i began
by asking for his verdict on the british
prime minister who of course has just
about survived his
i keep telling our people in pakistan
that this would not even have made news
here
you know the
in in in time of
government 19
uh prime minister having a a drinks
get together after work
would not even have made news here
because we also unlike the rest of the
world we also had to cope with
government 19 and all the restrictions
so
you know
here people can't understand what's
going on but i understand and i in one
way
this is one thing which i
feel that the reason why british
parliamentary system works
whereas
apart from
non-anglo-saxon
countries it doesn't work because of the
very high
uh
level of moral standards you expect from
your leadership
so
unfortunately it doesn't work in other
countries where they do not have the
level of moral standards
that you you expect from your
parliamentarians right i mean i think
that the issue here really is not about
partying it's about the hypocrisy and
double standard of a prime minister who
himself was fined by the police for
breaking his own lockdown rules and over
80 of his own downing street staff were
also fined by the police and it's the
brazen double standard of a group of
people that were ordering the british
public not to go even go and see dying
relatives dying from covert in hospital
they couldn't do that and at the same
time the people making those very
draconian rules
were brazenly breaking themselves i
think that's the issue
what stood out in britain was that high
level i repeat of
moral standards you expect from your
leadership
in pakistan you know the vote of no
confidence against me which took place
the whole country knew that the going
rate to buy my parliamentarians was a
million dollars
so i mean if you compare the two
uh that's why you know in my opinion and
i keep telling them of my experience in
british
of parliament
that unless we raise our level of
morality to what you have in britain
parliamentary democracy will not work if
you if all it takes is to buy 20 of your
members of parliament to switch sides
and a government falls
it it
in fact the whole concept of democracy
or parliamentary democracy then gets
challenged so you know from br from your
point of view in britain of what i know
i understand that you expect from your
leadership the standards you expect them
to delete by example
it's been very volatile since you were
deposed uh you vowed to come back and
fight again you think you're going to
win with a bigger majority i believe
but one issue that's come up in the last
few days there appears to be a serious
threat of assassination against you and
i have to say the last leader of
pakistan i spoke to was benazir bhutto
and it wasn't long after i met her that
she was indeed assassinated so this is a
very serious
risk that you all face i think when you
lead a country like pakistan
what do you know about these threats how
seriously are you taking them
well because what happened was that this
was clearly a conspiracy and
you know i've spoken about the
conspiracy because you know i came to
know about it about six months before i
actually uh before this vote of no
confidence took place
and uh
you know all the time i thought it
wouldn't succeed you know for some
reason i thought that
it's not possible that you know the
conspiracy was to replace me
by the guys who for 30 years had been in
power the two families
and there were massive corruption cases
against them
60 percent of the cabinet that has
replaced me is on bail or billions of
rupees of corruption cases so my mind
just wouldn't accept
that
would it be possible to replace our
government which was which had finally
recovered from all the two years of
crises and was on the way up
i just didn't think it would be replaced
by these criminals so
those who sort of planned this whole
thing
uh a bit worried now because they don't
want me back they didn't
take me out to get me back in again
so that's when i got
i found out that they had uh planned
this final solution but you were known
imran as on the cricket field you were
known as completely fearless no opponent
ever
put fear into you but when you're a
political leader and you're in the
situation that you're in now
uh where there's a genuine threat
against you of assassination do you feel
fear
no you know bears i it is well when i
entered politics i actually had
conquered my fear of dying otherwise i
would not have entered politics because
i came in to stand up against the entire
status quo i came
came to fight corruption
today the entire political
spectrum
16 parties on one side and i'm on the
other side
and because this was the status quo
which is
60 years of our last 62 years half has
been ruled by military and half by these
two families so i came to fight these
two families and this is really what i
i've done and they have made so much
money out of this that they obviously
clearly someone like me is a threat and
and that's why this uh
foreign-backed conspiracy involving
local players took place now
i know that they would uh try to my life
has had various threats over a period of
time but this time
i found out about this conspiracy so i
went public the reason i have no fear of
dying but it is it was important to let
those guys who are planning to let them
know that i know right it was actually
in a way a form of protection
well it says the next day in rancho
meeting with vladimir putin just hours
after russia invaded ukraine does he now
regret doing that
i promise you i had no idea i do not
believe what putin has done of
trying to find a military solution in
ukraine if i would advising president
putin i would not have gone there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back well russian forces began
mercilessly shelling ukraine on february
24th the day that president putin
launched his full-scale invasion but
hours later imran khan shook his hand
and sat down the talks in the kremlin
how does he justify that does he now
regret it
i promise you i had no idea i arrived
the night before i was only there for
one night next morning when i wake up i
discovered that this uh
uh
ukraine adventure had started
now it was uh
we discussed amongst ourselves
we realized that there was very poor
timing but at the same time we realized
that we really it was extremely
important for the 220 million people of
pakistan that we actually uh get this i
mean i understand that i understand
i completely understand that you didn't
know before you made the trip i guess
the criticism which may be legitimate is
that once you knew what he'd done to
then stay
there
and still go through with the meetings
that you had planned
sent the world a message that you
were not that upset by what he was doing
in ukraine countries like us
you know who have huge populations and
we have 100 million people who are
vulnerable right now so we should
actually
make policies have be have relationship
with everyone but make policies that
benefit our people i understand what
india is doing i understand what i would
say back to that is we talked earlier
about the higher morality standards in
the uk when it comes to holding leaders
to account
i simply would say i don't criticize you
for having planned a trip to moscow but
i think there is legitimate criticism
that once you knew what he had done it
illegally invaded a sovereign democratic
country
did your moral instinct not tell you
that it would be wrong to stay there
that you should have just got straight
out of there
piers i am against all military
operations i am i i
march with the with those two million
people in in london against iraq war i
constantly was against the afghanistan
war that there was no military solution
i do not believe what putin has done of
trying to find a military solution in
ukraine i always believe these are
miscalculations they cause a lot of
hardship and i did give a statement in
when i was in moscow that military is
not the military actions are not a
solution unfortunately we were left at
it at the the time was
either we then
and by the way the meeting was
more or less an r uh before
when we discovered that the the
they had invaded ukraine it was a
question of one hour in between to
decide whether we abandoned the trip or
or or or have the meeting with putin and
so eventually we decided that look at
this stage we will fall between two
stools
with russia we will break all
relationship leaving at this juncture
and at the same time you know is it
going to make any difference if we if
pakistan decides to sort of uh show uh
condem russian invasion by leaving there
are you in a position now to see what
putin has done
in ukraine
and emphatically publicly denounce it
any conflict and especially which where
you go and
any conflict creates bloodshed but
you know just like
in iraq in afghanistan god knows how
many people died there and similarly in
ukraine
going into uh ukraine the sort of uh
what we are saying right now
i am i'm sure that uh if uh
president putin realized what was
happening right now he wouldn't have uh
uh started this but do you personally
condemn
the war in ukraine now knowing what
you've seen in the last three months
let me just say one thing i
you know i am basically anti against all
uh operations so if you if you want to
uh ask me a question
uh do i condemn what is happening in
what happened in iraq i thought it was
wrong and i would condemn that i have
afghanistan u.s going in and then
staying okay once they once they got
decimated al-qaeda in the first year
what was the purpose of staying there
for the next 19 years so it was a
useless war and yes if you know if i
would advising president putin i would
not have gone there
and yes a war that creates bloodshed
and which is which it is and collateral
damage and civilians yes
let me ask you about afghanistan because
from the moment the americans led the
rather dramatic
and chaotic and many think disastrous
overnight pull out from afghanistan of
its forces
it it seems the taliban have basically
wrestled back control of the country at
record speed and are now going back to
running the country how the taliban did
before notably with severe oppression of
women in afghanistan what is your view
of that because you've been broadly
supportive i think of the taliban being
able to run the country again but are
you supportive of the way they treat
women there
let the people of afghanistan decide
which way they will go they're strong
people i found women are strong in my
opinion given a chance you will see them
asserting their rights but the last
thing we should do is
try to interfere in people of uh the
with the afghan government they're very
proud people
i know from experience that any hint of
outside interference in their uh
any country interfering in their way of
life they will
they're very uh
uh defensive about it i want to take you
back to the
late 70s the early 80s to
the genteel world of cricket where
you're a champion cricketer you were a
handsome playboy on the british social
scene with a number of girlfriends to
make all of us jealous
life was a lot easier for you then a lot
more fun a lot more carefree
you've become a very
powerful
uh very
divisive in some ways uh political
figure now in pakistan do you ever have
any regrets do you ever wish you hadn't
gone down the political path for me you
know life is not about
i feel that uh you know people who find
the easy way of life
easy way of life for me a purposeless
existence means nothing to me i have you
know i have everything i've ever wanted
in life so for me the challenge is
to actually go back make pakistan a
welfare state and
rule of law critical thing is
what you're seeing in britain is
basically rule of law which is one thing
i learned most of all when i went to
england as an 18 year old imam khan it's
great to talk to you again it's been uh
well nearly 50 years since i last talked
to you
uh last time i was steaming at you in
the next hove county cricket ground so
it's it's great to catch up with you
again and i wish you all the very best
thank you very much my pleasure
uh extraordinary character imran khan
one of the great ever sportsmen that
pakistan has produced and now this
extraordinary political figure and when
i'm sensitive next i'll be joined by my
stellar panel
the penis pack we're going to call them
they may not even want to be called that
but they're going to be called that
whether like it or not that's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah the production team had a lot of
fun doing that usain bolt promo you know
the idea it's like all exciting and fast
moving when it's about him and when it
comes back to piers morgan and sensitive
me it all screeches to a grinding slow
tortoise-like halt you get the joke
right anyway i'm delighted to be joined
now by the peers pack as we've called
them uh the author and playwright bonnie
greer general secretary for the free
speech union toby young a former
politician and author lord jeffrey
archibald great to speak to all of you
lord i want to start with you because i
was watching actually uh the camera on
you as you were listening to imran khan
because you're like me a massive cricket
fan um i think you were struck by two
things one the way he said he wished
that pakistan had a political standards
system as sophisticated as ours
and secondly uh when i asked him
directly do you wish you'd never go into
politics i could see you nodding
furiously as if you were sort of there
at the start of all that
thought process as well
that would be taking it higher than than
is accurate but he he asked to see me
50 years ago he came to the house of
commons
for lunch and he told me he was going to
go into politics
and i thought blimey that's you know
that takes a lot of courage and what
people forget and and your interview was
interesting in that way is what people
forget the years
he fought to become prime minister and
he failed and he failed and he failed
and he failed and he finally made it
and i i'm very proud to have even known
him because as you rightly say is one of
the greatest all-arounders the game has
ever known but he had the courage to
risk his life in
politics still still is risking his life
you know these assassinations are real i
remember meeting venezuela at a party
and
having a great time chatting to her and
thought she was incredibly impressive
and the next thing she was assassinated
bright lady and the second point he made
appears and was trying
to get over
and i accepted it totally was yes of
course
if you hold a party and break the law
you have put forward that's very bad of
course it is but what he's saying and he
was trying to get over to you peers is
you try
someone saying well i'll give you a
million dollars if you fix this building
permit i'll give you a million dollars
if you vote against imran khan i mean
it's in a different league and i think
what he was trying to say to you appears
yes what you think is bad it's not quite
what we think it is and i i completely
got that point yeah uh bonnie we had a
very animated debate uh to learn the
show about guns in america what did you
make of the matthew mcconaughey speech
because i thought it was pretty
spellbinding actually well please let me
just say something to you because i've
always wanted to say it to you let me
just say it
i really appreciate the stance
you took on gun control when you were in
america and had your show i thought it
was incredibly brave you were on late
night television and you just said what
you had to say so i've always wanted to
say this to you so other things i want
to say to you but that's what i
definitely want to say well thank you i
mean here's what i would say back to
that thank you for saying that but
when i watched mcconaughey yesterday i
wished actually i'd borrowed more of his
approach no no no no no no you did the
right thing because
you're in a country where you're a
foreigner okay let's let's and and you
never heard that you never hit who you
were when you had yours nobody got down
to a brit to tell americans yeah exactly
so you you you hit that you were close
to the wind anyway and saying it so you
did it perfectly didn't you feel when
mcconaughey the weight the way he didn't
set out to demonize gun owners or even
call for gunboats what he said was these
are the things we can do with surely we
can all agree well let's take on board
the fact that he's an incredibly good
actor yeah so he knows how to control a
room he knows how to work a room he's a
gun owner so he's not going to sit there
and say don't have any guns like me that
may be more powerful to me exactly so he
he paced himself
he gave the killer blow but it's not
going to make any difference right and
that's well that's what herod said it's
incredible not no different i i don't
know i hope it does something i hope
they can move i felt like with drink
driving it was a group of mothers who
rose up uh i think we called mad m a
double d and they rose up and they
slowly got traction smoking no there was
attraction together
can i say something i want to say to you
too into the audience
all the amendments of the constitution
are are
granted by the government that's how
people believe them to be
the second amendment is not granted by
the government the second amendment
amendment is affirmed by the government
in other words
people believe that god gave them the
right to have a gun yeah now we can sit
back there and go oh please but no no
people do they tell you and that's what
it is i understand tell me boris johnson
you like me have known him for more than
three decades
he has the ability of a particularly
slick eel to wriggle off any hook
just when you think he's done
he wriggles off yet again
are you surprised about what's happened
this week and do you think it's the
beginning of the end or do you think he
may just carry on well
over the course of those 30 years i've
never lost money betting on boris
johnson um people have written him off
before and they've always been wrong
it's very he's a very easy person to
underestimate i remember people laughing
when he became a conservative mp
thinking he's never going to amount to
anything in politics he just doesn't
have the temperament and now he's the
prime minister i think this i'm more
nervous now about putting my money on
boris than at any other time in the past
but i think he does have a few things uh
which mean that it may be premature to
write him off i mean i think unlike
theresa may he has a hard core of
supporters mainly brexiteers who are
concerned about the risk of replacing
him more so than they were and obviously
there's no obvious alternative and why
did the rebels shoot their bolt on
monday when they could have waited until
after well i would have waited till the
violation well the reason for that is
because they're a disorganized rabbit he
has
lord archer you were the deputy party
chairman of the conservatives what do
you make of party gate what do you make
of boris
should he continue as leader or is he
now so damaged it could actually bring
the party into a crashing defeat in the
next election
could i just put one point to two before
i answer that and i apologize toby don't
you think it's possible that some of
boris boris's own supporters
put in
letters to the 1922 committee because
they wanted the vote
before
the now that's a novelist talking there
jeffrey
you're compromising the script of your
next book
it's perfectly plausible and certainly
not beyond the machiavellian
machinations of conservative mps but the
problem is had it been manufactured if
the vote was manufactured by boris's
faction then why was the result not more
favorable to boris i mean it's provoked
this crisis actually he didn't win a
larger percentage of his mps than to
realize so it feels like if that was
their plan
i know you've got to go you've been
waiting no no wait wait okay
toby toby
i went to prime minister's questions
today and i assumed the leader of the
opposition would kill and he didn't he
actually got killed
would be on the floor he got killed and
frankly he got i totally agree it was
actually a very bad performance um very
bad lord i'm sure your book's called
over my dead body appropriately which
seems to be boris johnson's view of all
this thank you i know you've got to go
so thank you for joining us greatly
appreciate you looking great nick as
always look forward to reading the book
82 years old
you look amazing honestly um
bringing bonnie quickly on boris johnson
people say look this guy's a serial liar
he's a cheat he's a fraud he's all
business and he just carries on you know
boris is like donald trump and i i know
i want to go there but let me just
explain what i mean
boris and trump both understand
something about human beings we like to
be entertained aboris is very
entertaining boris is like that cartoon
that warner brothers cartoon the road
runner he always gets out he has an
audience of people who want to see him
escape
boris knows this also he has no moral
bottom so there's no morals there
there's nothing there that
gets in your way of thinking of you know
this is a bad guy this is a good guy
he's a he's a morals vacuum
so you can you can have that and you can
have the the sort of fun of watching
boris stick it to whoever you want to
stick it yeah it's a total entertainment
and but the problem is piers is that he
is lowering and i don't
he's hurting the moral fabric of this
country it's very serious situation and
i think a lot of conservatives at least
the ones who follow me on twitter these
people are nervous because what boris is
doing is calling up this idea of the
standards of this country he's just
trash
i agree but he's still there and they
probably can't get rid of him now for
quite a while thank you to my stellar
peers back panel that's all from me
tomorrow night usain bolt will be live
and unleashed of piers morgan uncensored
whatever you're doing tonight keep it
unsafe good night thank you
[Music]
i'm tony newton-dunn and this is talk tv
the most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did his interview went on i
is going to launch a nuclear strike on
north korea or even a shark pit that i
then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray and carrying it down
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zoro superman after the
biggest one-day jump in petrol prices in
17 years we're being warned it could
cost 100 pounds to fill up an average
family car that's if it goes up by
another penny with petrol now averaging
more than one pound 80 a liter
a teacher has been killed and 14 school
children are among the injured after
vehicle drove into a crowned invert
crowd in berlin a 29 year old man has
been detained by police
and former hollywood producer harvey
weinstein is facing two counts of
indecent assault against a woman in
london back in 1996 the met police were
authorized to charge him after reviewing
evidence but the cps has issued a
reminder that he has the right to a fair
trial but that's all for now we'll have
more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you